pour la Ligue des Champions les 8è de
finale de la Ligue des Champions le
parissgermain qui a terminé 2e de son
groupe et qui va sûrement se retrouver
avec un tirage difficile on va parler de
tout ça on va suivre ce tirage au sort
avec Sébastien fera bonjour Sébastien
bonjour bonjour à tous merci d'être avec
nous j'invite n inter bien sûr à poser
leurs questions on y répond au mieux
comme d'habitude je salue Tom je salue
Jacky qui sont avec nous dites-nous un
peu ce que vous pensez qu'elle serait le
meilleur tirage pour le PSG vous
n'hésitez pas Sébastien je le disais on
est on va être sur du lourd à priori
pour le PSG aujourd'hui euh ouais du
lourd bah on essaie de de discuter tout
à l'heure de qui pourrait ne pas être
favori face au PSG parmi ces ces
premiers groupes et il y a il y a pas
beaucoup d'équipes ça s'annonce
compliqué quoi qu'il arrive pour pour le
PSG effectivement on va prendre ces
équipes les unes après les autres mais
imaginons pour l'instant vous avez donc
les premiers de groupes et deè de
groupes ce qui va se passer vous le
savez on tire un premier groupe on tire
un deuxème de groupes de deux équipes
équipes du même pays ne peuvent pas
s'affronter et deux équipes qui étaient
déjà dans les phases de pool avant ne
peuvent pas s'affronter c'est bon pour
les règles exactement donc en gros le PG
peut jouer tout le monde en l'occurrence
sauf le Bruer DM effectivement par
contre Bayern domunich ne pourra pas
jouer contre leipsich par exemple
puisqu'ils viennent du même pays le
tirage va bientôt débuter bien sûr on
vous diffuse pas les images parce qu'on
n pas les droits mais on reste avec vous
ne vous inquiétez pas alors on disait
justement pas beaucoup d'équipes
favorites face au PSG quelles équipes
sont à éité absolument pour le PSG bah
il y a quand même des équipes qui
sortent un petit peu du lot on pense
forcément tout de suite au champion en
titre Manchester City euh qui paraît
encore très fort alors en ce moment City
traverse des des turbulances extrêmement
rares en tout cas rarement à ce point-là
là c'est vraiment très compliqué un peu
à relativiser aussi parce qu'il y a des
absents et surtout les les joueurs
majeurs comme Rodri de brun allant qui
sont peut-être les les trois joueurs les
plus importants de City qui était absent
le weekend dernier euh on sait que la
vérité à l'automne n'est pas forcément
celle au pratan le PSG est mieux placé
que quiconque pour pour le savoir donc
c'est plus à ce moment-là qu'on jugera
City mais c'est vraiment le gros le gros
poisson avec sûrement le le Bayern
Munich qui paraît quand même très fort
on a vu que c'est une équipe qui peut se
cracher qui a pris notamment un vilain
5-1 par Franfort donc on a vu que ça
peut très très mal tourner mais
globalement ça a l'air très fort et ça
reste avec des gros joueurs je pense que
c'est vraiment les les deux équipes
aujourd'hui que le PSG doit doit éviter
alors on évite City et le Bayern Munich
Arsenal Barcelone Madrid on n'est pas
favori non plus non euh non on n'est pas
favori non plus face à face à des
équipes comme ça surtout surtout Arsenal
je dirais qui est actuellement leader de
Première ligue qui fait quand même une
saison très très solide qui a vraiment
élevé ses standards aujourd'hui c'està-d
qu'il y a encore des petites critiques à
avoir sur l'équipe qui est pourtant
leader de Première ligue donc c'est dire
maintenant le niveau d'exigence et c'est
une équipe qui amener maintenant à à
vraiment franchir un cap qui qui a
vraiment cru au titre de champion
d'Angleterre la l'année dernière et qui
est vraiment amené maintenant à jouer
les les poids lourds en Ligue des
Champions aussi le Barça c'est une
équipe quand même qui tank beaucoup
c'est vraiment pas le pire tirage si
jamais c'est c'est le Barça pour pour le
PSG euh je pense qu'il y a vraiment un
capap entre Bayern Arsenal City et le et
le reste peut-être le Real un petit peu
au milieu parce que c'est toujours cette
expérience de la Ligue des champions
alors c'est une équipe qui est vraiment
pas épargnée par les blessures les
Français notamment chaminiavinga ces
derniers temps on a appris ce weekend à
labas fin de saison pour lui euh donc
c'est c'est c'est une équipe qui va être
difficile à jauger mais qu'on préfère
toujours éviter généralement en Ligue
des Champions effectivement et Real
Madrid Manchester City deux équipes qui
ont fait le plein lors de leur phase de
groupe donc le Real Madrid qui était
pourtant avec Naple et qui arrive à
faire le plein donc il faut toujours
s'en s'en méfier en dessous Atletico r
Sociedad finalement c'est un peu les on
a l'impression un peu les deux seuls où
ça pourrait jouer bien ouais peut-être
un petit peu alors c'est quand même deux
équipes pour le coup assez différentes
que ce soit dans le leur style de jeu ou
de par leur vécu forcément dans Atletico
il y a quand même beaucoup plus
d'expérience la realé sociéade a l'air
un peu de de petit Pousset de d'équipe
d'équipe comment dire disons que la
plupart des deuxiè de groupe seraient
plutôt contents s'il prennent la
sociedad voir éventuellement Dortmund
mais ça peut pas arriver pour le PSG en
l'occurrence mais effectivement la la
Real Sociedad c'est l'équipe
inexpérimenté de ses de ces premiers de
groupe euh maintenant c'est une équipe
qu'on peut pas sous-estimer déjà parce
qu'elle a fini première de son groupe
devant Inter Milan l'Inter Milan qui est
sûrement le meilleur deuxème de groupe
parmi la liste qu'on a aujourd'hui euh
c'est une équipe qui joue très vite et
qui tient encore la barre en ligue ils
sont plutôt bien là où il y a des
équipes par exemple on a vu le RC lance
qui a fait le pire début de saison de
son histoire en Ligue 1 euh notamment
parce qu'il fallait gérer la la Ligue
des Champions à côté euh la Real
Sociedad qui gère beaucoup mieux ça pour
l'instant après là aussi ils vont se
fatiguer la vérité d'automne n'est pas
celle du printemps et on verra comment
ils seront en en février mais ça serait
sûrement le meilleur tirage pour pour
pour le PSG et l'atleético Madrid
toujours compliqué oui toujours
compliqué c'est une équipe qui tient
encore bien la Baras en Ligue des
Champions bon ils avaient quand même un
groupe il avent pas le le plus relevé
des groupes ils arrivent à s'en sortir
en liguea ils ont Antoine Griezmann qui
qui marche sur l' cette saison qui est
absolument
exceptionnel donc ça reste une équipe un
peu difficile à à manier ça serait pas
totalement un cadeau mais ça serait
franchement pas le le pire pour pour le
PG dans les dans les deuxièm de groupes
on imagine aussi que forcément on
regarde nous vers les premier groupes
pour savoir qui éviter toutes les
équipes se disent qu'il faut éviter le
PSG euh bah le PSG ça fait quand même
partie oui je pense des des équipes à
éviter dans dans dans ces deuxième de
gros je pense que s'il y a vraiment une
équipe qui sort du L à ce niveau-là
c'est quand même l'Inter Milan qui a
perdu qu'un seul match cette saison en
en Série A qui a été finaliste l'an
dernier euh qui est vraiment un peu à
l'aboutissement du du projet de de
l'entraîneur Simon inzagi qui est
collectivement extrêmement forte solide
leader de Série A euh c'est vraiment
l'équipe la la plus costaud mais
derrière oui il y a il y a le PSG
effectivement euh qui est difficile à
jauger on l'a vu en Ligue des Champions
on le voit encore en Ligue 1 encore ce
weekend contre Lille c'est c'est très
difficile de de se rendre compte du du
niveau de ce PSG mais ça reste une
équipe qui par séquence peut peut mettre
vraiment des des coups d'accélérateur
qui progresse quand même globalement
collectivement même si Louis teste
encore beaucoup de choses il est encore
un peu à la phase laboratoire euh mais
ça reste une équipe forte et surtout
avec kyam Mbappé euh qui est très
fluctuant ces derniers temps mais là
aussi on l'attend sur les grands
rendez-vous et pas grand monde a envie
de croiser kyam Mbappé en Ligue des
Champions en 8e de finale mais en 8e de
finale le PSG reste quand même sur deux
éliminations coup sur coup une l'an
dernier une il y a de ans ouais ouais
ouais l'an dernier de fois des gros deux
fois cont des CAD he effectivement ouais
l'an dernier malheureusement c'était
assez assez triste à voir pour le coup
face au Bayern Munich où PSG a jamais
fait illusion
euh donc oui le le PSG ça reste un
groupe un groupe assez assez marqué par
ça et malheureusement par des joueurs
qui ont vécu quand même beaucoup de
dillusion maintenant Mbappé marquinos
donaruma qui qui on pas des très bons
souvenirs maintenant avec le PSG en en
C1 même si c'est un groupe qui s'est
quand même bien renouvelé il a il y a
quand même de quoijecter un petit peu du
du 109 en tout cas du un peu de
fraîcheur du du point de vue mental on
pense à Ugarte à za Emry évidemment donc
des joueurs qui peuvent apporter un
petit peu autre chose mais oui ces
derniers temps ça été des des vraies
désillusions et une autre élimination en
8e ça ferait quand même un peu un peu
tâche pour pour le PSG là effectivement
par contre il a a il y a des équipes
dans ces deuxiè de groupes qui sont plus
faciles que d'autres aussi on imagine
est que c'est quoi le l'adversaire le
plus faible le Copenhague c'est
forcément la l'adversaire le moins
référencé ouais totalement parce que
c'est que la deuxième fois je crois
qu'ils font des 8è de finale de Ligue
des Champions la dernière fois c en 2011
donc donc oui c'est une équipe qui
arrive sans aucune référence et qui est
déjà très très heureuse d'être là pour
le coup qui a qui a donc devancer
notamment Manchester United dans dans
son groupe qui est une énorme une énorme
surprise s aussi dans ce GRP exement et
et et donc oui c'est sûrement un peu le
le petit Pousset là des des des deuxè de
groupes euh derrière des équipes un
petit peu difficiles à juger par exemple
le PS vindoven qu'est-ce que ça vaut
réellement alors ils ont absolument ils
ont gagné tous leur match en championnat
nerlandais c'est une équipe qui qui qui
est quasiment déjà champion qui fil
droit vers le titre et qui qui a l'air
solide mais après qu'est-ce que ça vaut
en Ligue des Champions est-ce que est-ce
que ça peut passer un cap est-ce que ça
peut être à ce point-là Naple aussi
difficile à jaoger il a ch d'entraîneur
avec le départ de de Rudy Garcia la
Lazio qui n paraît pas forcément armé
pour jouer des des 8è de finale de Ligue
des Champions less chez Porto sont
peut-être un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus solides un peu plus référencé un
peu plus prêt pour en tout cas poser des
problèmes sur une double confrontation
comme ça alors que j Terry vient
d'arriver le défenseur central l'ancien
défenseur central de Chelsea qui est
arrivé dans la salle pour ce tirage au
sort qui devrait débuter d'ici quelques
instants donc on vous le disait euh ce
ce ce tirage au sort on va enfin savoir
qui contre qui va jouer le le PSG est-ce
que on le disit tout à l'UR il y a des
favoris clairs est-ce que mananchester
City est une nouvelle fois candidat à sa
sucession plus que jamais h oui j'ai
quand même envie de dire que si
aujourd'hui il faut distinguer un favori
ça reste quand même Manchester City il y
a quand même eu un assez bon début de
saison pour qu'on pense que ça va
continuer comme ça même si on l'a dit là
sur leurs six derniers matchs de
Première League on G ni qu'un seul donc
c'est un petit peu un petit peu
inquiétant un petit peu compliqué il
faut pas s'en s'en cacher mais ça reste
l'équipe la mieux armée la plus la plus
solide la plus forte sur quasiment
toutes les lignes collectivement on n
pas l'impression d'un d'un groupe qui
vit mal ou ou de choses comme ça donc
oui ça paraît quand même le favori euh
derrière je pense quand même que s'il y
a une équipe qui qui se Distin que ça
reste le Bayern Munich euh notamment
l'adaptation d'arikang qui a été
excellente
euh je pense que c'est un peu les les
deux équipes qui sortent du lot mais il
faudra un petit peu voir la tendance
aussi sur le début 2024 à l'au des 8è de
finale et sur les matchs allés pour se
rendre compte aussi est-ce que Arsenal
peut vraiment jouer ça sachant
qu'Arsenal vise vraiment le titre en
première legue est-ce qu'ils vont pas
dépenser un peu trop d'énergie là-dedans
aussi donc c'est quand même les les deux
trois équipes qui qui se distinguent
aujourd'hui ouais oui forcément avec
avec les blessures alors que on explique
pour l'instant le les règles du du
tirage au sort on vous rappelle on ne
joue pas contre une équipe contre qui on
a déjà joué lors de la phase de groupe
et on joue pas non plus contre une
équipe de son pays pour vous quel serait
le meilleur tirage pour le PSG on a dit
la Real socidan mais est-ce que il
faudrait pas aussi un peu de plus de
comment dire de pas de challenge mais un
peu pour pour monter en pour monter en
puissance bah généralement de quand on
regarde les précédentes éditions les
équipes qui vont loin n'ont pas
forcément toujours profiter d'un n pas
toujours profité en ayant un tirage
corsé dès le début généralement avoir un
tirage favorable d'entrée c'est quand
même plutôt bien de pouvoir
tranquillement monter en puissance et
puis parfois même vous avez jamais un
tirage finalement si corsés tout au long
de la compétition on a vu l'Inter Milan
la saison dernière qui a pas eu un
parcours extraordinaire avec c'était
c'était le FC Porto je crois en 8e
Benfica encart et là c'est Milan en
demi-finale avoir un derby de Milan en
demi-finale franchement personne
l'aurait annoncé en début de saison euh
donc donc c'est pas forcément un
avantage et surtout vu l'état du PSG vu
le temps qu'ils ont encore besoin pour
trouver leur repère euh je pense que
avoir l'équipe la moins forte possible
en tout cas sur le papier avec la Real
sociedade par exemple ou l'atltico de
Madrid ça serait ça serait plutôt pas
mal et bien nous allons nous allons voir
ce ce ce tirage au sort qui va débuter
d'ici quelques instants euh nous allons
vous analyser forcément ce qui va se
passer c'est c'est le le premier le
premier première boule qui va être tiré
de vainqueur de groupe alors il faut
faire attention aussi à pas se tromper
parce que on se rappelle il y a 2 ans il
y on a eu un petit problème ouais c'est
vrai et ça avait ça avait posé souci
donc c'est Arsenal Arsenal c'est le
premier club qui a été tiré Arsenal qui
sort d'une d'une phase de groupe face à
lance et qui va jouer contre le FC
Porto c'est une affiche bah il y a
clairement un favori mais c'est pas le
meilleur tirage que pouvait espérer
Arsenal parce que Porto c'est c'est une
équipe qui a fait déjà 8e de finale l'an
dernier qui est assez habitué à sortir
des poules de Ligue des Champions Qui
est qui est qui est plutôt solide qui
tient bien là-bas en championnat
portugais c'est ça sera pas un cadeau
pour pour Arsenal alors
deuxème deuxème affiche c'est le Napoli
qui est d'abord tiré donc le Napoli ne
peut pas jouer juste contre le Real
Madrid puisquil n'a pas d'équipe
italiennne qui ont terminé tête de série
on remarque d'ailleurs une énorme
présence des équipes espagnoles dans les
dans les dans les têtes de série et avec
notamment le PSG qui pourrait qui
pourrait affronter Napoli qui va un peu
mieux depuis que Rudy Garcia est parti
ça va un petit peu mieux ça cherche
encore quand même pas mal il y a il y a
encore du boulot c'est pas une équipe
qui a amené à jouer vraiment un rôle
normalement en tout cas dans dans cette
Ligue des Champions ils ont peut-être un
peu raté le coche l'an dernier sur leur
saison il marchait sur l'eau Naple
contre le FC Barcelone voilà une une
belle affiche ouais une belle affiche on
le disait le le Barça qui est qui fait
quand même une saison assez assez
moyenne assez assez décevante assez
assez frustrante globalement euh je
crois que ça fait il y a une énorme
série de matchs où ils n'ont plus gagné
depuis de où ils n'ont plus gagné par de
buts d'écart euh c'est vraiment une
équipe très très poussive Chavi est pas
mal contesté il se frictionne un petit
peu avec avec la presse euh Lewandowski
n'est n'est pas le le joueur qui digne
de son statut
euh c'est ça peut être un petit pièage
pour pour le Barça ça un déplacement NLE
et ben on verra ce que ça ce que ça
donnera avec euh maintenant le PSG le
PSG qui vient d'être retiré donc on va
connaître le quelle équipe jouera face
au PSG euh on est en train de tirer
cette boule pour savoir contre qui le
PSG va être tiré donc on a enlevé deux
équipes on n pas enlevé les très très
gros on n pas non plus enlevé les très
très petits donc pour l'instant ça
pourrait peut-être bien se passer
peut-être pour le PSG il nous reste donc
oh et ben le tirage est plutôt favorable
pour le PSG puisque ils ont obtenu la r
Sociedad c'est sûrement le meilleur
tirage que pouvait espérer le le
PSG c'est l'équipe la plus INEX enté de
de cette Ligue des Champions euh ouais
le PSG s'en sort s'en sort franchement
bien je pense miraculeusement peut-être
on pourrait le dire mais après la r on
l'a dit aussi faire très attention
puisque on est face on est quand même
dans une équipe qui a terminé premier de
son groupe face à l'Inter Dean à la
différence de buts certes mais en ne
perdant pas contre par exemple bien sûr
bien sûr c'est une équipe extrêmement
c'est aujourd'hui une équipe qui mise
beaucoup sur sur la vitesse qui est une
équipe qui a jouer vraiment très rapide
qui qui est bien travaillé depuis
maintenant un peu plus un peu plus d'un
an et comme on l'a dit qui tient bien en
même temps en Lig donc c'est c'est une
équipe plutôt plutôt solide qui a pas
l'air extrêmement fébrile extrêmement
fragile qui est donc qui qui a qui a
fait qui a sorti des bons matchs contre
l'Inter Milan contre le Benfica en Ligue
des Champions ça sera pas non plus un un
cadeau pour le PSG ça c'est clair ouais
ça sera pas non plus un cadeau c'est sûr
on verra la la réponse après perdre en
8e contre Manchester City ça donne une
bonne excuse mais par contre perdre
perdre en 8e contre là ça ça sera pas
possible encore une fois on verra au
moment les matchs arriveront les l'état
des équipes mais là sur le papier le le
PSG a obligation de de passer le weekend
de finale Inter de Milan face à
l'Atletico Madrid pour le la
4e confrontation une confrontation
plutôt équilibrée et qui s qui on attend
pas forcément un festival offensif sur
un match comme ça ouais et et alors
paradoxalement alors je pense que PSG
Real Sociedad on peut considérer que le
2è du groupe donc le PSG est favori et
je pense que là aussi l'Inter par par
favori face à Atletico donc l'Inter on
l'a dit finaliste l'an dernier euh inv
vaincu en Ligue des Champions une seule
défaite en Série A leader du du
championnat italien euh qui
collectivement apparaît nettement plus
nettement nettement plus abouti que la
plupart la plupart des deuxièm de
groupes et l'Atletico qui qui a qui a
des bonnes choses qui a encore des bons
éléments qui a encore une bonne base euh
mais qui a toujours du mal à à vraiment
maîtriser des matchs de bout en bout à
installer une vraie domination et
aujourd'hui en Ligue des Champions c'est
pas une équipe qu'on attend forcément
dans dans le dernier carré quoi alors la
5ème affiche est connue et ce sera le
PSV face au Borussia Dortmund pas
forcément une énorme affiche de Lig des
champions euh non effectivement c'est
une affiche qu'on pourrait tout à fait
retrouver en en Ligue Europa et pour le
coup Dortmund on on s'attendait pas
forcément d'ailleurs à ce qu'il soit en
Ligue des Champions avec ce ce groupe de
la mort qui AV avec le PSG et et et non
ça restera quand même une belle affiche
parce que le le PSV on l'avit avec LAN
c'est quand même une équipe joueuse une
équipe portée sur l'attaque encore gagn
3-0 contre la zakmar ce weekend en
championlat qui gagné tous ses matchs au
Pays-Bas euh et et Dortmund on sait
c'est quand même des matchs qui peuvent
vite être un petit peu un petit peu rock
and roll quoi ça peut aller un peu dans
tous les sens euh en bien comme en mal
pour eux euh pour le coup c'est quand
même une affiche qui qui peut promettre
un petit peu de de spectacle la suivante
affiche est connue aussi ce sera la
Lazio contre le Bayern Munich en en en
6e euh confrontation ladio Bayern Munich
a priori le Bayern est largement favori
là ouais le Bayern par largement favori
ça va être difficile pour pour
laaladio qui qui est pas qui est pas
habitué non plus au 8e de finale de de
Ligue des Champions là aussi comme un
peu comme pour PSG Real Sociedad par
exemple clairement le le Bayern doit
passer là il y a pas de il y a pas de
débat à voir et donc Copenhague
Manchester City pour la 7e rencontre la
meilleure équipe finalement a priori
face à la plus faible a priori aussi
ouais euh là on est clairement sur le
duel le plus déséquilibré des des 8e de
finale de de Ligue des Champions euh bah
ça va être dur pour Copenhague qui est
en même temps je pense déjà assez
content d'être là euh bah ils resteront
sûrement contents d'être là parce que là
normalement enfin un moin d'un à moins
d'un d'un cataclysme pour Manchester
City euh City en quart de finale et ne
tremblera pas face à face à copenhag et
le dernier affiche et donc le Real
Madrid face à leipsich euh Real Madrid
face à leipsich pour pour pour pour la
dernière affiche euh une affiche qui
pourrait être assez équilibré même si
Real Madrid est une fois de plus favori
ouais ouais ouais le le Real qui qui
part assez logiquement favori après
comme on l'a dit il y a il y a beaucoup
de blessés actuellement aujourd'hui pas
mal de joueurs qui ont été perdus sur
sur des blessures au ligament croisé
donc qui sont forfit pour le reste de la
saison donc c'est c'est assez assez
tendu quand même pour pour le Real mais
là c'est un peu l'équipe très
expérimentée face à celle qui qui a un
effectif toujours qui se renouvelle
assez souvent qui qui a du mal un peu à
s'inscrire vraiment dans la dans la
durée euh euh ça reste quand même une
équipe difficile pour pour le Real parce
que parce que c'est une équipe qui a
fait un bon parcours en face de groupe
qui reste euh problématique en
Bundesliga toujours embêté les gros les
Dortmund le Bayern euh Francfort
Leverkusen euh donc ça sera pas ça sera
pas évident mais le Real partira partira
quand même favoris ils ont quand même
une meilleure équipe et une équipe plus
expérimentée alors je regarde si vous
nous posez des questions Joë qui n
demande si on va commenter la TI de
l'Europa League non ce sera à 13h mais
vous pouvez bien sûr le suivre sur le
site du Figaro on vous le fait vivre en
direct sur le site et non pas en vidéo
cette fois-ci alors on va revenir un peu
sur ces sur ces différentes occasions
mais par contre on peut remarquer déjà
quelque chose c'est que le parisgermain
était quand même connu pour pas avoir
énormément de chance lors des tirages au
sort là ça va un peu mieux aujourd'hui
ouais là ça va là ça va plutôt bien pas
de real pas de City pas de Bayern pour
une fois euh non c'est plutôt
franchement un très bon tirage pour
enfin un très bon tirage la plupart des
gens n'aiment pas cette expression mais
on va parler de tirage abordable sur le
papier pour essayer de la de la jouer
bon communiquant mais non c'est c'est
c'est c'est une réalité c'est que le la
Real Sociedad était sûrement le premier
de groupe le moins fort parmi parmi la
liste et le plus le plus favorable pour
pour le PSG c'est une équipe qui a peu
d'expérience qui a peu de de joueurs de
de très très haut niveau qui rêverait
d'avoir la plupart des des joueurs du
PSG en il y a beaucoup de joueurs du PSG
qui seraient titulaires à la Real
Sociedad enfin je dis beaucoup peut-être
que je m'enflamme un petit peu mais il y
en a bien je pense si on fait la liste 4
ou 5 qu'il serait sans problème et
aujourd'hui la Real Sociedad n'a
absolument aucun joueur du niveau de de
kyia Mbappé même S a Tak fousa Kubo qui
est très impressionnant qui est vraiment
la sensation à la réal euh mais
aujourd'hui le PSG a des armes quand
même beaucoup plus fortes sur le papier
que la realé ou dans les commentaires on
me dit que c'est un tirage très
équilibré effectivement on n pas
vraiment de en 8e en général on a
toujours une grosse affiche là on a un
FC Barcelone naaple peut-être ou un
atthlético inter mais si on a pas la
grosse affiche des 8e de finale on a l'
non on a pas on a pas un gros choc bah
on aurait pu avoir par exemple un PSG un
PSG City un inter milan Bayern on les a
on les a évité donc non on a des
affiches
relativement soit en fait on a souvent
quand même un favori quoi qui se dégage
de de de ces confrontations on n pas
beaucoup d'affiches ou c'est vraiment du
du 5050 alors c'est du 5050 justement on
va faire un peu ces c'estes c'est ces
différentes match avec pourcentage de
victoire peut-être Arsenal FC Porto
c'est c'est combien euh Arsenal FC Porto
c'est quand même bien du je pense 80 %
pour pour Arsenal qui est qui est censé
en tout cas passer passer en qute de
finale et et et Porto ça paraît quand
même moins fort moins fort sur le papier
moins moins armé clairement FC Barcelone
Naple
euh si le Barça passe pas ça va vraiment
je pense faire jaaser parce qu'il a un
début de saison quand même déjà accompli
non le Barça quand même quand même bien
70 % favoris s'il faut donner un
pourcentage on serait sur C sur ces zo
là ouais PSG r je rappelle aussi que
nous sommes encore au mois de décembre
que ça se passera en février donc on a
un peu le
temps ça pe changer mais pour l'instant
PSG real sociate est-ce que c'est du
5050 ou quand même le PSG est en avance
non le PSG est quand même est quand même
censé être devant même si même si c'est
intéressant d'utiliser le terme en
avance parce que je pense que dans le
projet collectif en tout cas on peut
considérer que Sociedad est un peu plus
avancé un peu plus abouti sur sur ce
qu'elle veut faire sur un terrain de
football on a vu le PSG encore ce
weekend contre Lille sur le système de
jeu sur Mbappé en pointe pas en pointe
euh enore pas mal exactement ouais ça ça
cherche encore beaucoup et Louis Enrique
dit souvent ça dit que il faut du temps
il faut du temps il dit même queil
faudra peut-être plusieurs années avant
de voir le PSG être la meilleure version
de ce qu'il veut je sais pas si le PSG a
vraiment plusieurs années à lui donner
euh en tout cas ils auront pas ils
auront pas d'autres 8e de lui donner
celui-là il vaudra mieux il vaudra mieux
le passer clairement il va falloir le le
réussir Atletico Madrid est-ce que c'est
celui-là le le match le plus équilibré
ouais en tout cas c'est peut-être celui
qui se rapproche le plus d'un choc
l'Inter Milan c'est sûrement la le
meilleur deuxième de groupes qu'il avait
et l'atleético c'est c'est c'est quand
même un peu dans le dans le tiers du bas
on va dire au niveau des des premiers de
groupe c'est une équipe qui cherche
encore beaucoup en tout cas dans
l'optique de passer un de vraiment jouer
le titre en Ligue 1 en même temps de le
jouer en Ligue des Champions c'est pas
une équipe qui a vraiment l'effectif
pour c'est pas une équipe qui montre
qu'elle a cealapour sur le terrain en
tout cas dans des dans des matchs
vraiment complets dans des dans des dans
des chocs vraiment dans des victoires
référence c'est une équipe qui manque un
petit peu de ça qui se remet beaucoup
cette saison à à Antoine Griezmann alors
que l'Inter Milan apparaît comme une
équipe qui est capable aujourd'hui de
retourner en finale comme c'était le cas
l'an dernier c'est du 5050 non
l'interminant quand même favori
interminant favori PSV a dev Dortmund
c'est Dortmund qui est favori là ou
est-ce que la surprise du PSV qui donc
qui comme vous le disez fait une très
bonne saison au championnat pourrait
jouer la surprise ouais c'est c'est
vraiment difficile de bah déjà D est une
équipe très difficile à à jauger de
manière générale qui a tendance à à
décevoir lorsqu'on attend à surprendre
lorsqu'on attend pas c'est c'est
vraiment leur marque de fabrique donc
c'est c'est difficile de de de se faire
un avis sur on l'a vu sur le campagne de
Ligue des Champions il y a il y a
beaucoup il y a beaucoup de bonnes
choses et beaucoup coup de choses
vraiment à jeter mais on les v quand
même plutôt tenir tête en tout cas au
PSG sur exactement ils finissent au
final premier de ce groupe même si ça
été parti un peu dans tous les sens et
que ils s'en sortent plutôt plutôt pas
mal mais mais ouais on va donner quand
même le petit avantage à Dortmund mais
le PSV peut vraiment arriver très fort
et avoir le temps de préparer en tout
cas ce ce rendez-vous laad drrome Bayern
Munich 9010 pour le Bayern ouais ça va
être un petit peu ça là le Bayern là il
y a pas fruso il y a a il y a pas photo
le Bayern doit largement passer ce
tour la ladio ils ont franchement pas
beaucoup d'arguments pour vraiment
résister embêter le
Bayern après on verra comment le Bayern
va aussi gérer son énergie en Bundesliga
ou ou c'est c'est où la lutte fait rage
pour l'instant en tout cas au
sommet donc on verra et comme on l'a dit
le Bayern garde des petits signes de
fébrilité par moment il y a eu ce cche
5-1 contre contre Franfort qui
montre il faudra match retour voilà
c'est ça alors ça serait étonnant que ça
arrive à la ladio mais on voit que c'est
un groupe on sait qu'avec Tul ancien
entraîur du PSG ça peut être parfois un
peu Sud fureux ça peut vite partir un
petit peu dans tous les sens donc faudra
faire attention à ce que le groupe
tienne bien à ce que l'équipe tienne
bien jusqu'en février euh Manchester
City copenhag on est un peu sur les
mêmes ordres d'idées on a l'impression
955 peutêre même encore pire là je pense
parce que alors effectivement City il y
a eu quelques matchs compliqués mais ça
ira sûrement mieux avec le temps et
surtout lorsque de brun Allan rodr
seront revenus tous ils seront tous à à
100 % euh c'est clairement leur optique
d'arriver à 100 % à cette période de
l'année pour conserver leur titre
kopenhag c'est sûrement l'équipe la plus
faible des des 8è de finale sur le
papier normalement il y a il y a pas de
discussion à voir Manchester City doit
passer ce tour sans problème et donc la
la la dernière confrontation qui
opposera le Real de Madrid au à
lapsich ouais l'avantage est quand même
au Real hein on va pas se se leurer on
est sur du 60 70 % normalement euh après
on VI encore une fois avec quelle équipe
qui sera rétabli qui sera absent comment
celotti va va construire son équipe
d'ici là j'ai vu qu'on on parlait de de
d'avoir Aurélien chuameni en défense
centrale euh à force d'accumuler les les
blessés les et et donc et donc forcément
an celoti doit doit jongler un peu avec
ça il y a quand même faut aussi le
rappeler un mercato divers qui peut un
peu permettre de Red distribuer les
cartes de rééquilibrer un petit peu tout
ça euh leoreal par quand même favori
parce qu'ils ont avécu parce que c'est
le CL club de la Ligue des Champions ils
ont cette sérénité maintenant les psich
c'est quand même un peu un bon outsider
un bon trouble Fed avec notamment Chavi
Simons prêté par le PSG qui aura à cœur
évidemment de se montrer sur cette scène
effectivement voyez voilà le tirage au
sort de la Ligue des Champions les 8e de
finale auront lieu pour les phases allé
le 13 14 20 21 février et les matchs
retour 5 6 12 13 mars 2024 pour suivre
tout ça donc pas de tirage de Ligue
Europa en direct vidéo mais sur le site
du figero vous pouvez retrouver sur le
site du figero à partir de 13h pour
connaître les adversaires des clubs
français puisquil y en a pas mal en plus
pour jouer les barrages de Ligue Europa
merci beaucoup Sébastien d'avir avec
nous merci à vous d'avoir été nombreux à
nous suivre et moi je vous dis à bientôt
sur figero Live et sur le
figero